what would you do for a doughnut
[Laughter]
Adam Andrew y'all ready for season two
yeah let's do it we're gonna open up
this season with a bang and that Bang is
doughnuts today we're going to have
three doughnuts have three drastically
different price points to find out which
one is the most worth it at its price
this season may be the season that
people call the gold teeth the Golden
Ears the Gordon boys that's who we
should be I've heard that if you eat
gold we also poop gold I don't become a
little bit more gold now you excrete it
don't love that word even if are done in
number one I am ready for donut number
one all right let's go hi my name is
Theresa I'm the owner of Lincoln's
donuts in Woodland Hills and I'm really
happy to be here you've been here since
2002 and is this a family business sure
my uncle was baking today moms at the
register you know my massage you won't
let go of the register everybody's part
of the team blankies we're all a big
happy family today we're gonna have our
regular glazed doughnuts that's the most
popular one that we sell it's very
simple we're just gonna start with our
regular yeast doughnut dough mix it put
in a proofer cut it proof it again fry
and glaze with a regular lace icing how
do your doughnuts differ from sort of
the mass-produced doughnuts in terms of
flavor we just try to find the best
ingredients we can that's how it
available on the market and also make it
budget-friendly
so that everybody can come in and afford
a doughnut that or place this is the
Encyclopedia picture of a doughnut hole
some bum doughnuts
it's like the inside of a croissant
that's amazing it's so floppy my finger
doesn't disappears inside this time it's
a very gentle Jonah eating experience
this is truly the best doughnut I have
ever so the black of what is really
popular like a glazed doughnut is the
same dough fry it and then we'll just
let it cool down a little bit and then
we put on vanilla icing and our
chocolate icing which is a great recipe
you were saying you use a lot of
different kinds of chocolates why why is
I have different type of chocolate we're
quite picky on our chocolate taste and
we want to make sure that our customers
feel the same way and have the best
experience they call it the black and
white doughnut but others call it the V
or the Batman or the tuxedo this whoo I
like this
the icing on most Donuts can be
overwhelming but actually it adds a
perfect cake we've got that same great
base and follow disco rich chocolate
really is good because you only get that
streak you can really enjoy it and pick
your bites a little more it's not
overwhelmingly chocolatey all the streak
was weird at first but I like that it's
only covering a little bit Stephen
thought it was weird anything else weird
I'm telling ya go ahead oh my god a new
strap myself Adam would you like a
sample you like that yeah go ahead and
take the rest esta semana no dream of
these donut Santa Santa I don't know how
anybody didn't beat that donut just
based on value experience quality donut
like it had everything watching her
uncle work that guy's a straight-up
donut wizard the donut door the donut
Dumbledore Dumbledore nut Dumble donut
yeah Dumble done' ready for a light and
airy donut effects co-wrote fact it is
believed that the dutch are actually the
ones who brought the donut to america
during that time actually donuts were
not cause donuts they were called the
translation is oily cakes say the word
though that is all let's go holy Co holy
Co holy Tex I like one a name for
something is just literally what it is
it's like man's water
we're going now to a very different
doughnut experience and this time it's a
brioche doughnut just fancier mean
better that's what we do we find out
where the fancy boys welcome to the
church key I'm the executive chef Reino
sauce key we're going to be making our
brown butter glaze brioche doughnuts
today and how did you come up with the
idea to have done it on the menu I knew
I wanted a brown butter glaze
you know something on the menu our
pastry chef kind of just said I'm going
to take what chef wants this brown
butter glaze and I'm going to put on a
doughnut and we never look back we have
the dough that's been proof doubled in
size we roll it out here we cut our
donuts out do the second proof of the
donuts before they go in the fryer then
we take our portion don't we serve three
Donuts we fry them at 325 degrees for
about five minutes we make a brown
butter glaze which is brown butter
powdered sugar salt vanilla so it's
going to get salty sweet kind of a nutty
flavor from browning the butter I think
what stands our donuts out is equal ace
and serving them warm I think it is
truthfully the deciding factor on what
makes our doughnuts great about to
consume three delicious doughnuts with a
milkshake on the side we're not to be at
the same time you can start I'll go next
I'm waiting all right here we go mmm
it's mostly the PB the J is a little
more hidden but I like that it's
streaked around the outside it's a very
pretty milkshake
oh nice right it's like um it really is
like I'm can you get out of mine okay
nice and thick what I like about it
let's move on mmm this one is weighty
last one was fluffy it's gonna be a
weapon it is very cute though it's such
a perfect place come on don't bump
hmm did not expect that salt hit I feel
guilty eating this it's like taking a
bite of a delicious stick of butter
that's coated in all of these amazing
flavors
that's how melty it is the icing is a
little bit bitter from the brown butter
and it really makes this very satisfying
bite it's like an evolving flavor story
in your mouth mmm it is exactly like you
agreed with you t-bone when I said that
I agreed with you and it just came out
that way
what'd you think I thought after place
number one that blinkie's would win but
now I'm like okay got some awesome
competition now Church key donut opened
up my mouth to a whole other Avenue of
flavor called
saltiness whatever you're eating just
gets just exploding your mouth base your
tongue in its flavor goo LLL moving on
here's effect you do not want to miss
don't affect the world record for the
most Jam donuts consumed in one minute
is three that's it yeah I feel like I
could beat that easily we're our way to
the final spot the golden donut I've
never eaten an item of food covered in
gold why do I want to eat gold it's gold
yeah it's gold you don't that's why you
want to eat gold it's gold
[Music]
hi I'm Joanna
I'm the assistant general manager here
at Verdes and this is Katie and the
managers you should feel pretty what is
this magical place we're in right now
basically everyone loves fried chicken
and Donuts our co-founders restaurateur
Keith Bay and celebrity chef Jay decide
to combine those two things and this is
how they came up with it you just make
fried chicken and doughnuts yes
how would that life fancy it's messy fun
fun the dough Negus what we having today
is going to be a chocolate cake doughnut
we start off with dark chocolate dough
which we roll out we fry off once it's
cooled down we cut it in half we fill it
with the strawberry jam that we make
in-house fill the ring with Nutella then
we spoon our champagne glaze over it and
cover it with gold leaf the champagne
glaze will get absorbed into the actual
dome so you'll get a little bit of that
champagne seeping into the dough it's
not just going to be covered in the
glaze how does it feel for you of his a
chef laying gold on a doughnut I think
the first time I thought I was like
really like we're gonna do this really
but I guess now that I do it so often
it's normal seeing a go doughnut is not
normal I'm excited if you'll kind of
weird chocolate Nutella strawberry
champagne gold doughnut
I don't feel like anything in my life
has prepared me for this moment I'm
really excited
not specifically because it's gold but
it looks like something that you
lady in the [ __ ] absolutely not okay
that your mouth and my mouth we're gonna
exist on the same plane time and space
this is Dan your your powerful air here
we go
[Music]
whoa look I kissed a leprechaun it is a
really moist doughnut too
what do I do with the gold on my fingers
you'd be likely a waste to wipe it oh
don't eat it I gotta take another bite
yeah I did you there is kind of this
alcoholic back tastes a little bit with
the icing which is really nice it's a
very magical experience you're eating
gold but you're also like drinking the
glass of champagne as well here I have
this solid gold nugget it seems like I
just broke it off a chandelier
eight into it turns out it's filled with
jelly that's a magic that I think is
worth experiencing a colleague of mine
she claims that she pooped gold that's
going to happen I'm really into that
great okay Adam you're getting in there
[Music]
I kind of feel like my throat is coated
in the gold like I have kind of an itch
at the back of my throat I feel great
which doughnut was the most worth it at
his given price point the church key was
really a special tasting doughnut a
salty caramel hold Blinky's is probably
the most worth it for me that basic
glazed doughnut that they make is just
so good adding anything to it it's just
downhill from there the gold doughnut
one-of-a-kind literally it was
legitimately a very good doughnut but I
gotta say blinkie's is also my wor that
winner after what 50 years of being open
they've just completely perfected the
doughnut crack Adam whose you're worth
it winner
do we just three-way on a doughnut I
think it's kind of worth it trio I think
it's called uh worth ah ha ha ha ha no
oh oh yes